this right here is exactly where you're
going to make your money as an architect
if you're exceptional at elevation
design especially in 3D as well as in 2D
you can do exceptionally well in your
career So today we're breaking down
elevations and showing you exactly how
to document them in Arc CAD what's going
on team welcome back to the channel my
name's David tomich I'm a registered
architect here in Western Australia and
this is the completely free archicad
course right here on YouTube Welcome
Back to episode 8 where we are focusing
on this beautiful elevation you see
before us we need to make this thing
absolutely stunning and we're going to
do that both in 2D and in 3D so let's
start by jumping up to our floor plan
and moving up to our Upper Floor I think
there's just subtle ways we can really
manipulate this and make it even better
so let's start by grabbing this external
wall moving at about a meter connecting
it with our other external wall and just
simply reconnect connecting these
Corners jumping back into 3D we'll see
straight away pushing it out gives us a
little bit of a cantilever over this
floor Edge and makes it just stand out
that little bit more our slab in the
middle is for whatever reason the wrong
color and so is most of our building if
I'm being honest what I want to do is
select all of my external walls command
T open them up change my material to
some sort of white let's go to Titanium
white which is absolutely fine for now
this allows us also to change the slab
Edge to Titanium white so if I press OK
find all the walls that weren't selected
previously make sure they go white as
well we're starting off with a pretty
basic White House next we want to extend
our slab all the way across to the edge
of the balcony align it with our
external walls and then add a little bit
more to this design because at the
moment it's pretty basic it's pretty
boring so what we created up here before
was a little planter so what we need to
do here is go to our mesh tool and
introduce a little bit of fill or Earth
so if I change that cross change it to
Earth Brown
we can see now that's a perfect little
planter for either some cascading plants
a little tree or anything in between we
don't have too much room left on our
site but we want to maximize the width
to make this thing look really really
wide so we've come back to our ground
floor plan right click show us Trace
reference for our site plan we can see
how far across we can go so if we use
one of these walls extend it all the way
to the boundary come back to our 3D
we'll see we've created something quite
large we then want to copy that wall
directly to our ground floor plan as
well this is going to allow us to make
this building look bigger than it
actually is
so how wide do we want to make it well
personally I probably want to make it
about as wide as this window to really
allow maximum width here we can
introduce a nice cascading green wall to
really give this house some punch
looking from the street a beautiful
white black green design is going to be
simply stunning and it's going to stop
everybody in their tracks
what we do need to do is actually give
this wall some stability though because
that will never stand the test of time
if we also do that on the Upper Floor
Plan you'll see we've boxed it out a
little bit given it some actual strength
and stability but also faked most of it
because that there is just an
architectural feature personally I don't
like this window right here so what I
want to do is actually extend it up a
little bit and then break this elevation
some more so what I'm going to do is
push this wall back another 500
millimeters reduce the earth I created
and cut that slab out now we've given
this some definition some bulk some
articulation and we've broken it up a
little bit it is very very bulky still
even at this stage and it is still a
little bit squished but there are
constrictions on this site so we're just
going to leave it as it is coming back
to our first floor plan I want to
introduce a louvreed system over this
garage so let's go into our object let's
type in shade and just use a simple
solar shade if we change those pen tools
like we previously we discussed change a
layer to roof structure let's just go
roof covering for this one drop it into
our garage and manipulate it so it fits
the way we want it to if we come back
into 3D we see what we've created is a
Louvre over our carport but we want to
give it some more louvers it's way way
too open and not actually what it'd be
like when it's constructed so let's
change these figures from four to maybe
25 that way we have a ton of louvers
available to us we also want to change
this to Wood so it matches our Louver
screens finally we're going to need to
introduce a column as well we haven't
talked about columns too much but if we
drop a column in by simply using the
same settings that are by default go
into 3D see where it landed on the wrong
floor straight away let's drop that to
the ground floor press ok
we can extend the column similar to how
we've done everything in the past go
through these settings change the size
of the column to what we want it to be
so let's say we want to be 100 change
the material to Wood change the
structure we want it to be some sort of
Timber structural column press ok so
what next how can we further this design
how can we make it even better well at
the moment it's pretty boxy it's pretty
basic it's still pretty boring this wall
I still believe needs to come even
further so let's push that out another
500 mil just to really continue to give
this house a bit more Grandeur in the
overall design extend everything to suit
this new parameter and there we go we're
starting to get a bit more Grandeur in
this house we're starting to make it
look and feel like it's worth investing
in our time and our services
as part of elevation design you
obviously want to do this in 2D or 3D
whatever you're most comfortable with
personally I love designing in 3D
because you get to see it from every
single angle all the time rather than a
generic 2D shape
2D shapes are great up front but it's
not what it's going to look like in real
life you really need to see it from
every angle every axonometric possible
and just keep working through it now if
we come back to our first floor plan
turn off our Trace reference and zoom
out a little bit you'll see a number of
markers on the left hand side if you
don't see these markers you can create
them on the left either by the elevation
or the section tool today we're talking
about the elevation tool specifically
next week we'll talk about section tool
what you want to do is select your very
first elevation marker I like to start
with elevation 0 1 at the front of the
house rather than elevation 3 as it's
depicted by default here
so what I need to do is Select that
elevation marker rotate it 180 degrees
and then drag it in front of my house
typically when you document elevations
you document them from the boundary you
want to know where the natural ground
level is at the boundary and also where
it is at the house so I'm going to move
it back here for the purposes of this
and then we're going to move it a little
bit later as well
if we go to command T open up these
settings you can make this elevation
marker look like however you want
there's not that much critical
information here that we need to talk
through but what we do need to talk
about is to cut and uncut elements
whenever you're cutting through
something in elevation you don't really
want to be that's more specifically for
sections but if you are you want to
leave it as cut and unshaded uncut is
everything else visible in the actual
elevation so you can change this to a
whole bunch of different settings let's
press OK open up our elevations and you
see it's completely in color if I come
back to my floor plan open up those
settings and change this let's go color
fill non-shaded press OK double click
back on elevation zero one you'll see
once again completely changed except
what we're cutting through elevations
are something that change over time as
you progress in the construction
documentation process at the start you
probably do want to have them as a
surface textured feel to really give you
as much information as you possibly can
for this let's leave it as colored fill
and scroll down a little bit further
there's two more things that we want to
pay attention to here fade distance
elements if we tick that box and press
OK you'll see an additional line appear
if I go back to my elevation one
everything behind that additional Line
is now grayed out so if you're making a
clear reference to distance for example
we only want to focus on the front of
this project here we can focus only on
the front of that project and shade out
everything else if you want to step that
you can step it as well adjust it pull
it back change it however you see fit so
you get even more context and even more
grayed out very specific to how you want
to operate now personally for this
project we don't really need it there's
not too much going on so we can untick
Cafe distance element what we want to
focus on next is our sun settings now
there's two ways to present elevations
you can present it with a custom sun
setting so every single elevation looks
to have the same Shadows over it
otherwise you can display it as per the
3D window which is accurate to your
actual surroundings and environment the
accuracy of the in 3D window is very
helpful as you design to understand and
how that sun is hitting each individual
wall so make this as a design Choice As
you move across now if we come back into
elevations what we actually need to show
is a few documentation elements in the
elevation first of all we want to show
our natural ground level so if we go
text General and
let's use boundary for example pick a
color whatever you want let's go General
drafting black we want to be able to
show where the natural ground level is
at the boundary which is exactly where
this object is cut so if we create that
line first go back to our floor plan
push in a little bit closer to the house
go back to our elevation
we can now see where the actual natural
rail level is at the house as well which
is quite a big difference between our
street and our actual house so now if we
create a secondary line go back to our
marker place that marker whatever we
wanted to actually be in the project we
could actually turn off this layer so if
we go right click layout and hide layer
we don't need to see that layout but we
do need to know that we need a little
bit more Earth towards our house to make
this work so what are we going to do
there well we actually need to indicate
that on these elevations we need to tell
the builders and everybody making this
project how we're going to do that
there's a whole bunch of different ways
a whole bunch of different standards you
can do this you can simply do it as a
white fill line you can do it as Earth
you can do it as colored patterns
changes whatever you really want it to
be so in this instance literally just to
make this really really clear for
everybody I'm going to select a blue
color I'm then going to highlight a
section 50 mil below this slab that
needs to be blue and then the rest of
this I'm just going to make a secondary
shape again literally just for the
purposes of this video this isn't how
you actually document documentation is
relevant to your country to your
standards everything in between but this
is how you would demonstrate that
there's a little bit more cut a little
bit more fill and additional information
required if you wanted to make that
white as well you could just to really
clear it out and then add a little bit
of text as well the text is critical so
let's start with NGL at boundary let's
change that black and then we can also
go and create a secondary note FGL for
future ground level now just like we
created these text notes we also want to
create specific notes so let's use the
line tool and turn on one of our arrows
so coming up the top scrolling all the
way across we can select our arrows we
can select that Arrow style and the
arrow color all of this personal
documentation preference however you
like it you can have an arrow you can
have a DOT you can do whatever you like
it's completely up to you guys just
simply start pointing to different
elements in your project so we want to
talk about the render we want to talk
about the doors we want to talk about
potentially the cappings and the
flashings on top of the roof when we've
annotated most of the elements we want
to talk about we want to make sure our
documentation is neat and tidy there is
a reason good architectural
documentation are what they are and
that's for the very simple fact that
they're carefully thought out from every
detail that means everything is aligned
everything is perfectly thought through
and you can see there is intention there
so let's start by adding a little bit of
a text note everything on elevations has
to do with the architectural intent
there's no structure here we're just
talking about colors materials finishes
maybe want this glass to have black tint
so glass with black and we can leave it
that we can keep it quite simple we
don't have to go into too much detail at
this stage you can annotate however you
like next up the top we're going to have
our custom parapet capping and what do
we want it to be do we want to be metal
do we want it to be rendered what do we
actually want this to look like on site
this is where the architecture is
critical and the details matter for me
personally if it was all rendered in
Australia here I could use a Master wall
Skyline render to match wall and that
simply says to the Builder on site that
this is going to be a completely
rendered capping sealed to the
specifications and we can document all
that as we build more and more detail
onto this project with time and as we
progress we can add more and more notes
to our documentation what you'll also
see on the side
is two different elements happening
white and gray and an extension of the
actual screen these gray elements are
the extents of our elevation marker so
if I extend the elevation marker ever so
slightly further come back into my
elevation that gray becomes wide up now
this isn't really that important and
it's personal preference as you're
documenting it won't be shown when you
export this PDF so what I personally
like to do is just right click and turn
elevation range off to just make it a
lot simpler a lot cleaner next you'll
see all of our markers here on the left
at the right hand side if you press
command 7 like we did at the very very
start or control seven if you're on
Windows
you see all of these boxes here are
ticks what we want to do is untick them
to get rid of them we'll keep them
ticked if you want them when you're
documenting elevations you also want to
actually indicate where each window is
what each window is what the seals are
and much much more now if I do all of
these details we'll be here forever so
if I just show you simply what we would
intentionally do if we only had 2D lines
we would simply draw a 2d line measure
the Seal of that window to the bottom of
the house so we're going to call that
four meters for now and adjust that
there we also then want to repeat that
for the top of the window head which is
simply going to be another two meters
above that now personally I wouldn't be
doing this in 2D I'd be using the 4D
window marker which makes life so much
easier and just to Showcase how simple
it is we can select our course we can go
millimeters from Project zero let's drop
it in rotate it to where we need to be
and then we can simply adjust it change
it and it will automatically change the
heights Boris so I wouldn't be as
personally be doing it in 2D I'd
definitely been using an automatic
system like this
very similar to the door window markers
which we'll get into a little bit later
that's all for me team thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed it smash the
Subscribe button if you want more the
playlist to the side of me has this full
series but like always I'll see you next
Monday